[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight happy June
so yesterday CNN held townhall specials
with a trio of presidential candidates
Seth Moulton Eric sois well Tim Ryan we
watched it so you wouldn't have to all
three of them are Democratic members of
Congress none is in danger of becoming
president anytime soon so why do we pay
attention to what they say well because
as they stammer and sweat and pander
profusely they give us a pretty good
idea what Democratic primary voters
believe and what they care about and of
course the thing they care about most
the thing they can't stop talking about
ever is race they're obsessed in a
deeply unhealthy way racial obsessions
are always deeply unhealthy watch Seth
Moulton explain that Georgia didn't
elect stacey abrams govern ott because
she wouldn't be good governor but
because you sir are a bigot we have a
problem with racism in america today if
this country wasn't racist stacey abrams
would be governor people of color are
being systemic ly denied the most basic
right in a democracy which is the right
to vote so Seth Moulton went to Andover
and Harvard unlike you so he must be
unbelievably impressive probably a
verified genius and a good person too
and yet somehow Moulton didn't bother to
muster a single piece of evidence to
show that any of his claims were true
because actually they're not true
because it's not 1953 anymore
they can't let you know that though for
Seth Moulton purposes purposes of
control it's got to be Jim Crow Alabama
at all times now and forever burning
crosses in the sound of night writers in
the distance that will keep you
terrified and easier to manipulate
that's the whole point
Eisenhower sent the hundred and first
Airborne to bring the south to heal but
the modern Democratic Party doesn't need
the military instead they've got big
business to make the population obey
watch Eric's whoa well of California bow
before the gods of woke capital you have
Netflix Disney NBC Universal Warner Beat
media which owns CNN they've all warned
they may halt business here
now if that law does goes into effect I
wonder do you support that kind of
economic boycott yeah if that law goes
into effect I absolutely do and CNN may
have to move there's a lot of young
women who work at CNN to be effective do
I support putting big companies in
charge of America's social policy Eric's
wall has asked of course I support that
screw voters they're relevant our
billionaire donors will bring back the
abortion fairy you'll notice applause
from the audience they love that
Democratic primary voters love it when
you talk like that that some
billionaires gonna ride to the rescue
and make everything okay you know what
they don't like they don't like reality
that infuriates them biology is real
Russia did not beat Hillary global
warming isn't actually killing millions
of people right now all true statements
all of those statements drive them
bonkers because they're true watch their
response when Colorado Governor John
Hickenlooper who's also running for
president reminds them that actually
socialism doesn't really work if we want
to beat Donald Trump and achieve big
progressive goals socialism is not the
answer I was reelected
I was you know if we're not careful
we're gonna end up helping to real like
the worst president in American history
so that's the point where Hickenlooper
should have paused and called out the
audience like a stand-up comic and asked
them to name a single place outside of
Sweden in the 1970s in which socialism
has actually worked anyone anyone but of
course he didn't do that he was too
afraid
moist Palme Democrat God knows what the
mob would have done if he tried watch
what happened to John Delaney
maybe the bravest of anyone in the race
when he suggested that medicare-for-all
might not be such a great idea
medicare-for-all may sound good
but it's actually not good policy nor is
it good politics I'm telling you
I'm telling you
a hundred
[Applause]
oh he's dying out there oh stop him
before he hurts our dreams if we want it
to be true it must be true screamed two
four-year-olds in attendance I am the
center of my universe cater to me tell
me I'm wonderful if you strip it all
away that really is the message of
Democratic voters 200-proof narcissism
give us more the narcissist in chief was
very offended for the crime of making an
obvious point
congresswoman Alexandria Kazuya Cortes
went on Twitter and demanded that Elena
get out of the race and that doesn't in
the end bode well for Democrats when a
party demands delusion that means only
the delusional can win